you had a real messed up childhood I I
had an odd childhood it was a lot more
messed up tonight then I thought
apparently according to the team of
doctors you know when I see your
biography on TV and stuff and Soma I
mean I was I was kidding about it before
but it doesn't kind of said I mean you
grew up in a car I was watching some
some Jim Carrey biography or something
and it was like your dad was don't cry
couldn't hold a job you and your whole
family lived in a car and had to like be
janitors together yeah but you know what
through that came the man you are today
yeah we had some tough times yeah sure
no no was there any sort of like hey
we're on an adventure kind of thing no
honestly at the beginning well you know
when my father lost his job I was pissed
I always liked those things he's the
smartest guy in the world how could I
exactly the thing was he wasn't happy he
would come home and get something in
that damn guy man I tell you one of
these days I'm gonna you know so I don't
know what happened you know who knows me
was miserable there well you know as you
ended up living in a contact Lee well
you know I ended up yeah sure and like
trying to be the adult and trying to
take care everything I'm fascinated by
this yes I mean because people would go
around to you know one time we for a
while we pitched a tent on my sister's
lon
really in a country and then for a while
we went to camp sites around you know on
tomorrow and you know we'd use the
facilities there and we actually had a
lot of fun we had more everyone there
than we did when we were doing this job
that we didn't like the janitor job yeah
the janitor job and you was amazing by
the way
putting believable experience so your
dad was the janitor your mom was the
janitors and security guard slash
security guards in every doll family my
father would come to relieve me from my
8-hour shift and there would be a new
hole in the wall in the office and I'd
have some trumped-up excuse the the
buffer it just it flew out of my head
like you would punch the walls you saw
yeah man I was 15
Wow and they used to the the factory
workers used to mess with my head
like taking you know defecating in the
sink you know and is a duty isn't clean
at all man I had to do the whole thing
but the whole time I was singing and I
was dreaming me that's really screwy oh
yeah you had to be angry with your old
man okay boys for a while you know but
my dad was cool man my dad you know I
mean you know you go that's the one
thing about therapy they like they kind
of focus you on like oh what did your
parents do what did they do right
what you know what did they what do they
not give you and all that and yeah sure
I mean in certain ways they made me grow
up fast right but you know the the list
of what they did for me was so enormous
it's a sad story I don't think so no I
honestly I do I mean I have a very
positive attitude about those sort of
things I really think that you know it's
it's that old theory of the moth being
born out of the cocoon all right so you
have a little stronger you are you
watched wrong now that's right Deepak
strong when you have a lot of money as a
result of growing up or now that you
have a lot of money now you're a
superstar and you make 20 million a film
yeah is this still pressure for you you
just don't care anymore you know you
always want to do well you know I mean
you want to stay in the business you
know I mean but but you know I'm
constantly just coming up with ideas and
throwing them in so if you hire Jim
Carrey for a movie you're paying for a
guy who can ad-lib so you might her so
you do your thing yeah but what's it
like for the other actors like they like
I don't know when I shot my movie they
said to me don't ad-lib here because
it's crucial to the story and you gotta
really don't they don't know exactly
that I do well yeah unless it's like you
know on the page like friggin
Shakespeare you know unless it's
something like you know like Charlie
Kaufman Kaufman's movie that I just did
is pretty on the page it's like that guy
writes but everything means something
you know so you don't mess around with
it too much but there's still
opportunities when you know when you do
scenes where you know like Ace Ventura
you got to let go wild that's what
people got to keep it alive you know
that the best stuff is the stuff at the
last minute
like when you talking with your ass
thank you for all your cooperation by
the way do you have a minute
no one's gonna write down that no you
just say I'm gonna talk with my exactly
and I was born on in living color
actually that that whole bit because I
was I was angry and one day right movie
like the majestic or yeah that's it you
gotta get serious yeah you gotta get
serious but there's still there's still
like when you have little moments of
life together they they'll say okay you
in love and you're running through field
whatever it is you have to create
moments those things are hard to do
honestly I we think every day and I
opened my eyes and I go I'm doing this
amazing thing for a living I sound it
sounds ridiculous but I I'm constantly
pinching myself and going like I can't
believe this